[Musik]
>> ELA: Mama, kann ich dir den allerwitzigsten
Witz erzählen?
>> SALLY: Ein Witz?
Ja, erzähl.
>> ELA: Ja.
Eine Karotte ist in der Rubine drin.
Und dann geht die Karotte
in die Eier rein und macht ein Eierbad.
>> SALLY: Wer hat gerade gepupst?
>> ELA: Ich nicht.
>> SAMIRA: Ich nicht.
>> SALLY: Viel Spaß, Josh!
>> SAMIRA: Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Samiras und...
[Trommelwirbel]
>> ELA: Samira soll es sagen.
>> SAMIRA: Hallo und herzlich willkommen
zu Samiras und Elas Welt!
Heute zeigen wir euch, wie Smarties Muffins
hausgemacht leicht gehen.
Wir haben
>> ELA: Butter!
Zucker.
>> SALLY: Sag einfach, was ihr da so habt.
>> SAMIRA: 150 Gramm Butter,
100 Gramm Zucker,
eine Prise Salz,
einen Teelöffel Vanilleextrakt.
Zwei Eier, die sind in Raumtemperatur.
180 Gramm Mehl,
ein bis zwei Teelöffel Backpulver.
>> SALLY: Einen halben.
>> SAMIRA: Einen halben,
einen halben Teelöffel Backpulver,
>> SALLY: Sehr gut.
>> SAMIRA: ein viertel Teelöffel Natron.
50 Gramm Buttermilch ist auch in Raumtemperatur.
20 Gramm Kakao.
50 Gramm Buttermilch
ist auch in Raumtemperatur.
Also
die Muffins,
das sind Marmor Muffins
und da ist einfach eine
Schokoglasur drauf.
Und deswegen fangen wir jetzt
mit dem weißen Teig an.
>> ELA: Okay.
>> SAMIRA: Zuerst müssen wir die Butter nehmen.
>> ELA: Die ist ja immer weiß.
>> SAMIRA: Ja, die muss ja auch weich sein.
>> SALLY: Die Ela davor...
>> ELA: Weiß, sagte ich. Weiß, nicht weich!
>> SALLY: ...die Ela da nicht.
>> SAMIRA: Ja, ich weiß es auch nicht.
Ja, aber Ela hat halt die Schüssel dahin gemacht.
Ja, Ela, mach das mal rein.
>> SALLY: Salz und Zucker.
Nimm die ganze Schüssel, Ela.
Sonst verlierst du mehr.
>> ELA: Eins, zwei, drei!
>> SAMIRA: Mach.
>> ELA: Salzschlacht!
>> SAMIRA: Zuckerschlacht.
Dann...
Wir haben jetzt den Zucker reingemacht und
die Prise Salz.
Danach kommt die Butter rein.
>> ELA: Soll ich dir ein bisschen helfen?
>> SAMIRA: Nein, danke.
>> ELA: Dann mache ich wohl die Vanille.
>> SAMIRA: Mach ein bisschen Vanilleextrakt rein,
aber nur ein bisschen.
[Trommelwirbel]
Einen Tropfen.
Guck, Ela.
So.
>> ELA: Wow.
[Musik]
>> SAMIRA: Wir werden das jetzt...
>> ELA: Backe, backe Kuchen.
>> SAMIRA & ELA: Der Bäcker hat gerufen.
>> SAMIRA: Wer will frischen Kuchen backen,
der muss haben sieben Sachen:
Eier und Schmalz,
Zucker und Salz,
Milch und Mehl,
Safran macht den Kuchen gehl.
>> ELA: Aber...
>> SAMIRA: Achtung!
>> ELA: Hör auf!
>> ELA: Die Eier.
>> SALLY: Einfach so hinhalten.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Eins nach dem anderen, Ela.
>> ELA: Und dann
>> SAMIRA: Achtung! Pass auf!
>> ELA: schön verrühren.
>> SAMIRA: Nicht zu....
>> ELA: Ein Ei.
>> SAMIRA: Warte.
>> ELA: Schön verrühren,
damit man nicht mehr das Eigelb sieht.
>> SAMIRA: Ich stelle es mal ein bisschen höher.
Jetzt tun wir
die trockenen Zutaten rein.
>> ELA: Ich mach!
Ich mach! Ich mach!
>> SAMIRA: Also Mehl und so weiter.
Die Ela verrührt jetzt den Kakao mit...
Was noch mal?
>> SALLY: Buttermilch.
>> SAMIRA: Mit der
>> SAMIRA & ELA: Buttermilch.
>> SAMIRA: Und ich habe gerade
>> ELA: Ups.
>> SAMIRA: die andere Buttermilch mit Mehl
hier reingemacht.
Ach so, ich hab es nicht mehr angemacht.
>> ELA: Ich brauche ein bisschen noch mehr Buttermilch, Mama.
>> SALLY: Wofür?
>> ELA: Weil es ist zu fest geworden.
>> SALLY: Ja, stimmt.
Samira, du kannst jetzt schon mal hier was reintun
von deinem Teig.
So ein Drittel ungefähr.
Weißt du, was ein Drittel ist?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
Also so ungefähr die Hälfte.
>> SALLY: Nicht so.
Guck mal, beim Dritteln,
Drittel heißt ja, dass man es durch drei teilt.
Das heißt, ich mache mir hier so eine Linie,
hier und hier.
Und alles, was hier jetzt drin ist,
das hier,
ist das Drittel hier.
>> SAMIRA: Hä, warum das Drittel?
>> SALLY: Weil ja noch Kakao dazukommt
und dann ist es später ungefähr die Hälfte.
>> SAMIRA: Gibst du mir die Schüssel?
>> ELA: Schön verrühren!
>> SALLY: Ja, schön verrühren.
>> SAMIRA: Hilfst du mir?
>> SALLY: Soll ich es dir hier kurz rausmachen?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> ELA: Rühren, rühren, rühren, rühren,
rühren, rühren, rühren, rühren.
>> SALLY: Da reicht ein Drittel.
Denn es kommt ja noch Kakao dazu.
>> ELA: Fertig?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Gut, Ela!
Jetzt stelle ich mal den Hellen kurz zur Seite.
>> SAMIRA: Mach,
mach den...
Nein! Nein!
Das schmeckt gar nicht!
So.
>> ELA: Guck.
>> SAMIRA: Ela!
>> ELA: Entschuldigung.
>> SAMIRA: Das sieht irgendwie wie Wackelpudding aus.
Ich habe jetzt den Kakao mit der Buttermilch
und mit dem Teig zusammengemacht.
Und das rühre ich jetzt.
[Musik]
Ela, warte!
>> SALLY: Einer von euch macht hell, einer macht...
>> SAMIRA: Wir sollen kurz warten.
>> SALLY: Ja. Einer von euch macht dunkel.
Und, Samira, nimm du den.
Und mach ihn nicht ganz voll.
Eher so.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Weil eigentlich hätten wir zwei kleine gebraucht.
>> SAMIRA: Wir
machen das jetzt immer abwechselnd.
Mach du mal.
Du musst von dem eins reinmachen.
Ich mache von dem ein halbes rein.
Okay?
Also wir machen das jetzt abwechselnd,
dass ich jetzt hier ein halbes nehme,
weil das ja ein bisschen größer ist
und Elas kleiner.
Und deswegen macht sie von dem eins rein
und ich von dem einen halben.
So entsteht der Marmorkuchen.
Gut machst du das.
Das ist ein bisschen wenig
bei dem einen.
>> SALLY: Ihr macht ja dann erst mal auf alle auftragen
und dann kommt ja noch mal drauf.
>> SAMIRA: Ach so.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: Was ist los, Ela?
>> SALLY: Was ist los, Ela?
Was machst du?
Keiner weiß, was sie da macht.
>> ELA: Also ich zeige dir mal
so ein Ding
was nicht ich ist. Okay?
So ein Satzzeichen.
Fragezeichen. Okay?
>> SAMIRA: Mama, mach nicht alles leer!
Wir wollen auch noch naschen!
>> SALLY: Ja.
Okay.
Noch mal.
>> SAMIRA: Würde eigentlich auch ein Teig ohne Eier gehen?
>> SALLY: Geht.
Da kann man Leinsamen dann nehmen.
>> SAMIRA: Und was ist, wenn man
gar keine Eier reinmacht oder Leinsamen?
>> SALLY: Fehlt halt so ein bisschen die Bindeeigenschaft.
Das Ei, das hält ja auch den Teig zusammen.
Warte. Noch nicht.
Hier fehlt noch ein bisschen.
Holst du mal eine kleine Gabel?
Ich zeige dir jetzt noch einen Trick.
>> SAMIRA: Ela!
>> SALLY: Ela, nicht so viel naschen!
Sonst kannst du keinen Muffin mehr essen.
Hast du mich gehört?
Nicht so viel rohen Teig naschen.
>> ELA: Trotzdem.
>> SALLY: Wegen dem Mehl.
>> ELA: Ich esse eh keine Smarties.
>> SALLY: Sondern?
>> ELA: Muffins.
>> SALLY: Aber dann pack jetzt nicht alle aus.
Wir brauchen nicht alle.
>> SAMIRA: Das reicht jetzt. Okay?
>> SALLY: Ja. Das reicht.
Die brauchen wir später, okay?
So.
>> SAMIRA: Dass man den Marmoreffekt hinkriegt,
muss man einfach nur eine Gabel nehmen
und innen drinnen nur einmal drehen.
Und dann ist da so ein kleiner Marmoreffekt drin.
So.
[Musik]
Voll verkleckert!
>> SALLY: Was für ein Spaß ist das!
Sag wem.
>> JOSH: Achtung. Es tropft.
>> SALLY: Hört mal. Es tropft.
Vorsicht.
So.
Jetzt einfach bei 200°C 20 Minuten. Okay?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
Ober-/Unterhitze.
>> SALLY: Und ihr könnt ja solange aufräumen.
Ihr könnt ja solange aufräumen.
[Musik]
>> SAMIRA: Also die Muffins sind jetzt...
>> ELA: Fast fertig. Jetzt fertig.
Sie waren im Ofen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und jetzt sind sie?
>> SAMIRA: Die Muffins sind jetzt schon abgekühlt.
Und
jetzt machen wir gerade die Schokoglasur.
Und...
>> ELA: Und dann machen wir die Smarties drauf.
Die sind nämlich hier unten.
>> SAMIRA: Und...
>> ELA: Jetzt sind sie hier durch.
>> SAMIRA: Also, wenn dann die Sahne köchelt,
dann nehmen wir sie vom Herd runter
und machen die Schokolade rein.
>> SALLY: Genau,
das, was noch übrig ist
was ihr nicht weggenascht habt.
Und dann könnt ihr die bestreichen
und die Smarties darauf dekorieren. Okay?
Und ich mache solange unser Mittagessen.
>> SAMIRA: Das riecht so wie eine Suppe.
Jetzt köchelt die Sahne.
Und
>> SALLY: Ja, jetzt mach...
>> SAMIRA: jetzt mache ich den Herd runter.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt Schokolade rein.
>> SAMIRA: Und jetzt mache ich die Schokolade rein.
>> SALLY: Warte.
>> ELA: Ich will! Ich will!
>> SAMIRA: Das geht jetzt gerade nicht, Ela.
>> SALLY: Da. Halte es mit dem.
>> SAMIRA: Das ist zu heiß.
>> SALLY: Jetzt von hier halten,
dass man es auch noch sieht.
>> ELA: Ich will aber auch mal!
>> SAMIRA: Die
Schokolade...
>> SALLY: Das ist eine Ganache.
>> SAMIRA: Das ist ja eine Ganache.
Und
die hat jetzt so eine dickflüssige Konsistenz.
Und ja.
>> SALLY: Fertig.
Jetzt könnt ihr es bestreichen.
Ela, komm.
Komm.
Guck mal. Fass mal die Schüssel an.
Jetzt geht es wieder. Okay?
Aber gerade eben war die Schüssel zu heiß.
Hier. Das darfst du jetzt machen.
Hier.
>> SAMIRA: Oder soll ich das machen und du bestreust?
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Ein bisschen mehr Schokolade.
Dann schmeckt es noch besser.
Guck, so. Warte.
Guck, so.
So viel kannst du hier draufmachen.
Was ist der Papa?
>> ELA: Unromantisch.
>> SALLY: Unromantisch?
Warum?
>> ELA: Weil er auch ein typischer Schwabe ist.
>> SALLY: Ein typischer Schwabe?
>> ELA: Und unromantisch.
>> SALLY: Und unromantisch?
Okay.
[Musik]
Guck mal. Da kannst du noch ein bisschen draufmachen.
In der Mitte.
>> SAMIRA: Ups.
>> SALLY: Huch.
>> SAMIRA: Fast hingefallen.
>> ELA: Mama, mach meine Ärmel vor!
Ich verkleckere die!
>> Josh: Die sind leider da und da schon ein bisschen verspritzt.
>> SALLY: Die Ärmel sind nicht das Problem.
>> SAMIRA: Den Letzten.
>> Josh: Ja, ja.
>> SAMIRA: Njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam, njam.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Komm. Ich mach hier noch ein bisschen drauf.
Und dann könnt ihr ja die Smarties drauflegen.
Macht ihr das?
>> SAMIRA & ELA: Ja.
>> SAMIRA: Und nicht so viel wie gestern.
>> SALLY: Ja. So wie auf dem Bild.
Probiert es mal wie auf dem Bild, Ela.
Guck mal.
Auf dem Bild da ist einfach so eine Smarties-Blume.
>> Josh: Das hast du noch mal schön gemacht.
>> SALLY: Ela, mach dir so eine Smarties-Blume.
Zeig.
Samira, du hast überall Schokolade.
Ist jetzt egal.
Darf ich probieren?
Euren...
>> ELA: Erst
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> ELA: machen wir fertig.
>> SALLY: Aber ist der noch nicht fertig?
Normalerweise müsste man sie jetzt
natürlich noch trocknen lassen, nicht?
Darf ich den probieren?
Oder den?
Ich nehme den.
>> ELA: Den!
Mama!
>> SALLY: Sollen wir den mal teilen?
>> ELA: Du darfst gleich meinen probieren.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Achtung. Ich gebe euch auch ein bisschen.
Ich probiere mal vom Kuchen.
>> ELA: Li, li, la, la, la.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
Magst du beißen?
>> SAMIRA: Da ist auch ein schöner Marmoreffekt drin.
>> SALLY: Oh, voll schön!
Voll gut gemacht!
>> SAMIRA: Gib Check!
>> SALLY: Magst du auch beißen?
Richtig lecker!
>> ELA: Richtig lecker.
>> SALLY: Und die Zubereitung war ganz einfach, oder?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und wie gibt es das Rezept, Ela?
>> ELA: In
Sallys App!
>> SALLY: Ja, genau.
Also, falls ihr Lust habt, das Rezept nachzumachen,
schaut auf Sallys App vorbei.
Das ist doch dein Video. Du musst fertig moderieren.
Ist nicht mein Video.
Das ist euer Video.
>> ELA: Und...
>> SALLY: Sagt einen Abschluss.
>> ELA: Wenn ihr alle Rezepte wisst,
braucht ihr kein Kochbuch.
Kein Kochbuch.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> ELA: Nichts Fertiges.
Ihr braucht einfach nur
das, was ihr zu Hause habt.
Wenn ihr nicht so viele Zutaten, wie wir haben, habt,
geht,
verratet es uns...
Du musst sagen: "In den Kommentaren."
>> SALLY: Ah. In den Kommentaren?
Voll der YouTuber!
Schreibt es in die Kommentare, sagt sie.
Aber, Ela, du kannst doch nicht sagen,
die Leute brauchen kein Kochbuch.
Die wissen vielleicht nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Aber dann können sie in der App nachschauen, nicht?
>> ELA: Guckt.
Und wenn ihr keine Zutaten habt,
geht auf den Globus.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Dann geht einfach einkaufen.
Bis bald!
Tschüss!
>> ELA: Und kauft ein.
>> SALLY: Und dann?
>> ELA: Und euer Handy kann euch auch unterstützen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
[Musik]